It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
BAU BAU!
And today Ruffians, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Only today.
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today!
For our 126th episode!
Only today.
Ruffians!
Thank you, Ruffians!
You woke up 5 minutes ago!
Good morning!
You're perfectly on time!
Yeah!
Good morning!
Perfectly on time!
What about the Ruffians that have been up for a couple hours, Moco-chan?
You're early.
You know what?
Early worm.
Wakes up early.
BAU BAU!
Well, for the Ruffians that are joining us today for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Monday through...
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please say your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you awake now?
I'll awake in one day, that's what I mean!
Have you been a bit sleepier than regular?
Well, maybe this week won't help.
It's time to wake up, Ruffians!
Again!
Yeah, I know.
The seasons are changing.
It's going from summer to fall.
Yeah.
But time doesn't mean you can sleep in, okay?
Maybe sometime.
You're tired this morning, but you're up now!
Maybe we can make you feel a little less tired.
Yeah.
Well, how are we gonna start this week out, Moco-chan?
Does something awful make you feel less tired?
Maybe it depends on the Ruffian.
I know that awful things make me want to just go back into bed, but... My strength is gone!
Maybe it'll be shocking!
Well, let's shock the Ruffians awake!
Okay.
There's been another Pero Sighting.
What is he been saying now, Moco-chan?
De-den!
Oh, that's a pretty snuggly and nasty looking perro there!
Nasty?
Is he trying to take over your bed?
Bed?
I think the Ruffian, did you notice something?
Imperial think he's gonna take over your bed.
Think he's gonna have a bit of a tough fight in front of him, no?
You know.
Look!
Look, Ruffians!
Do you see?
Yeah!
This Ruffian has very fierce tiger bedsheets.
Is that a bedsheet?
I think so!
It's so fancy!
Right!
Fancy?
I don't know, Moco-chan.
I'm a little intimidated by them too, no?
Right.
Fancy.
I don't know.
Is that a bedsheet?
It's scary.
Intimidating.
Fierce.
Pero's gonna have a hard time.
Let us know how it went.
I'm sure it was easy for you.
Just keep them out.
BAU BAU!
Wow, I like the matching caps.
I'll mark it right off his head.
BAU BAU!
Exciting big news!
Just over this weekend, iHololive English Dice and Fun!
All of hololive, they celebrated their 4th anniversary!
BAU BAU!
It's amazing, Ruffians!
4 years!
4 years of hololive English!
4 years of hololive English all together.
Oh my gosh.
We're so happy!
I know.
They were saying that when they joined, their senpai were celebrating their 4th year.
That's a long time.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, but now we're here!
We get to celebrate the 4th anniversary!
And watch all of hololive go into their 5th year!
Their 5th year in hololive!
And do it so in style with our 3D anniversary live!
Yeah!
It was so amazing to see them all sing and dance together, you know.
Reunion!
Journey like a thousand years.
I know, I was really happy to hear reunion again after, you know, Breaking Dimension.
It got me so teary.
I cried too long.
But then not only did they just sing the songs all together, but then they split off to sing each other's solo songs individually and also in units too!
I was really surprised!
That was amazing!
Yeah!
The shuffle was so incredible!
Right!
It was really cutesy!
Kiara-senpai have sing to Chikutaku, you know?
Yeah!
End of a life.
End of a life is cute.
It was amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know, it's just, it really brought back a lot of memories and emotions to Ruffians!
Right!
Yup.
Then you know everything kinda has to come to a close.
And it will make sense that, well, near the end, they're gonna perform their brand new song, The Show Goes On!
It's gonna end with a big bang!
Big bang!
Brand new song!
Yeah, you know, and The Show Goes On, it's an amazing show too!
Wow, and very fitting of the Broadway, like, stage that they were dancing on!
So cool!
Yeah, so jazzy!
It's unlike any other hololive English song so far, so please go check it out!
It's now on Stringling's services!
So don't forget to add it to your playlist and listen to it lots to locate!
Everyone's dresses are so cute!
Right!
Kelly-senpai's shirt is very blood red.
Oh, I wish I could be tucked in.
I don't know, Ame-senpai looks like a little doll there.
Right?
So cute.
Yeah.
I wanna see Ina-senpai spin and spin and spin and spin.
But now that I ask, she probably won't do it.
Because that's how it goes with Moco-chan, right?
FUWAMOCO Congratulations on your 5th anniversary event!
FUWAMOCO Congratulations!
FUWAMOCO We're so so lucky to be your kouhai.
FUWAMOCO And we're wishing you all the best of luck on your 5th year in hololive!
FUWAMOCO A big congratulations.
She did.
Calli-senpai did her best.
Yeah.
I think both were the best.
Both very very good in their own ways.
In their own ways, you know.
Yeah.
Mococo split suit!
Do you wanna kill Moco-chan?
I can do the splits.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm right Mococo!
I'm left Mococo!
I'm not Fuwawa!
Together we make FUWAMOCO.
And together we make FUWAMOCO.
It's gonna get awkward and then everyone's like, are they twins or are they twin boys or what?
What's going on here?
Please don't make Moco-chan do the Spitzelkin Ruffin.
Please do not.
To crash and fight and carry someone.
BAU BAU!
We'll have BAUKANOKO!
What?
No!
I want to combine the BAUKANOKO together to make Mococo!
BAUKANOKO!
Yeah.
But!
That's not every exciting news!
Oh!
Speaking of new bodies!
Ah, I didn't think I'd be talking about new bodies, but here we are!
Hi!
Wow!
A very special senpai!
Right!
She just announced a release of a brand new 3D body!
Yay!
And because she doesn't split anything, don't be confused.
No!
No
We got noisier than FUWAMOCO and we can get a lot more noisier!
Especially when talking about Morning Deja Vu's new body!
And the new body is also the same new body as the body that my 3D Papa gave me!
So we have the same new body but it's just kinda different!
That's not it at all!
It's really noisy!
Papa is the same.
Okay?
The papa is the same, okay?
We can be noisy too!
Have you watched this before?
Ruffians, did you take a look?
Very very cute!
If you haven't seen it... De-den!
I see!
That looks pretty seventeen, don't it?
You say it like you wasn't seventeen before, huh?
I was!
Wow!
Very cute!
Look at that leg!
Thank you.
Wow!
Hi!
Marine-senchou-senpai unveiled a new music video!
Music video of an original song called Paipai Kamen de Dou Desuka?
How about Paipai Mask?
It's amazing!
So shiny!
So blue and so sparkly!
Everything's everywhere!
Very Marine-senchou-senpai!
Very cute!
Wow!
Just wow in a music video format.
It was sexy.
If you're expecting masks and pie pie.
You're probably expecting it.
Yeah.
So go check it out!
Yeah!
But!
But not just an original song!
It's an amazing music video and amazing 3D body!
Not just that!
You can't stop it!
Marine-senchou-senpai wanted to surprise us even more with her very first solo concert!
And not just one day!
Not one day.
It's two days!
Two days!
And...
Ruffians, I wanna- How can we go watch?
I wanna go watch!
I wanna be there!
But it's not just two days.
It's not just two days.
Arena two days!
Arena!
K-Arena Yokohama!
Hai!
That's a 20,000 capacity.
Two days.
Two days of that.
Huh?!
I love to have such amazing senpai!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, that's crazy!
Two days.
Yeah, 20,000!
Yeah, and I don't know!
I need to go to both days!
I'm finishing my account.
Yeah!
But we're so happy and so excited for Marine-senchou-senpai!
It's gonna be absolutely amazing!
Yeah!
I don't know, it's just... You know, when you see Marine-senchou-senpai doing these amazing things... We're just like, how...
How?!
I like to... I like to even be... What's it?
One-tenth.
Yeah!
It's amazing.
But we'll get there!
One day we'll be big senpai just like Marine-senchou-senpai!
We'll work our hardest so that maybe we can be one tenth someday.
And we'll be cheering her on lots and lots!
Good luck Marine-senchou-senpai!
Omedetou!
BAU BAU!
I think we were pretty noisy just now, right?
We'll continue working hard.
Cuz we're working hard.
But!
Back to some other exciting news!
Nerissa Alvarez!
She just made her debut in holography!
Did you watch it, Ruffians?
What is holography?
Well, it's a special anime that's hosted on the hololive official YouTube account.
And every week there's a new episode.
And for the past few weeks, Advent has been making their debuts in hologram.
Ruffians, you've been watching them, right?
Yeah, Shiori and Biboo have got these too.
Oh, what did you think?
What did you think?
I haven't seen Nerissa.
Go, go, go!
Go check it out!
Yeah, it just came out, so it's brand new, fresh Nerissa.
Fresh Nerissa!
You know, it's been really amazing watching them and seeing everyone come to life in hololive.
You know, they captured their personalities and everything so well.
Oh, Nerissa!
She just aired yesterday!
You can see nice.
Her nose and clothes all together with Oshino Kiara-senpai and Marisencho-senpai.
Singing like a demon of sound wave!
If you don't know what that sounds like, you're good to go!
Go check it out!
Okay!
Liquid comes out from the ears.
I didn't know liquid comes out from your ears.
You have to go see a doctor.
Just in case.
I think the liquid should stay in the ears.
I think it should too, but... Well, since it's a demon of sound, you know.
Yeah, soup ears.
Yeah.
Luna, when you eat soup, it doesn't go to your tummy, it goes to your ears!
Apparently.
Well, you know, it's Shiori and Biboo and now Nerissa that all made their whole grand debut.
I guess that's everyone.
Well, I was gonna say, you know, that might kind of mean that that's everyone.
That's everyone.
It stops there.
Where's Pero?
I think you should get ready for disappointment then.
Maybe that might be now?
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO might be soon!
I'm really nervous, Ruffians!
Ruffians, please BAU BAU lots of special messages for us in the comments, okay?
Okay!
We're gonna do our best, okay?
We're looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
Lots of exciting things going on!
Keep on coming more and more!
On a topic of horror!
H-O-L-O-G-R-E.
There's something.
You make a little bit of a typo.
Just make a typo and you have something new.
Something new kind of like hololive GTA!
Oh wow!
Mika-chan-senpai and Sui-chan-senpai just announced!
De-den!
hololive GTA!
It's a huge project between all branches of hololive.
You know, JP, ID, EN.
And the fight is week long!
And!
Well, you know, we're all gonna go into the world of Holosanto.
Yes!
For a bit of an explanation, so this is roleplay.
Yeah!
Okay!
And there's also a limited duration, so it only goes for a week.
And the server is only open from 7pm GST to 1am GST.
So that's...
3am PT.
Yeah.
And then, you know, tonight we have PT.
After FUWAMOCO Morning.
But you know, for a bit more of an explanation, there's a bunch of different teams.
So there's the gang team, the police team, medic team, mechanic team, and civilians and services, and of course the host.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Which team is FUWAMOCO on higher?
Mechanical?
No, no, no.
Not the mechanic.
Oh!
Yeah!
Medical Camp!
We're playing the QQ time!
The QQ time we're gonna save everybody and be really QQ while we relax them and heal them.
And do all the things that make them feel better inside.
The top medic is Fubuki-senpai!
So we're gonna do our best to make Fubuki-senpai feel smart.
And then, you know, no mistakes.
And then hopefully, you know, we'll see how we decide to pass the time all together.
There's lots of different things you can do together for fun, right?
Yes!
But we're going to be playing the entire week.
And we're going to be doing our best because this time, this is the very first time that our paws have ever touched the GTA game ever ever ever ever ever.
We don't know what to expect at all.
No.
We have not seen anything GTA.
I don't know what's possible in the game.
And we feel washed up.
So we're gonna do our best!
It looks like real life!
We're gonna do our best to heal everybody.
There's a lot of buttons.
We don't have a driver's license.
I don't know.
Am I fit to be a medic?
What could I do our best?
But because the runtime for this server will be going past the regular time for FUWAMOCO Morning, this is the only FUWAMOCO Morning just for this week.
But we will still be live here on YouTube every day!
So we hope, Ruffians, that you'll come to check out how we're doing and hold us on toast and cheer us on too, okay?
And also, in case you already know, MTL!
I will also be back for hopefully the majority of the event.
It's very long.
You know there'll be JP-senpai there.
ID-senpai.
EN-senpai.
So there's gonna be a lot going on.
We're all gonna be doing our best to communicate.
And it's gonna be interesting.
There'll be a lot of passion going on too.
Lots of passion.
No crying.
Maybe some cries.
Please cheer us on and follow us on Twitter!
That is a guarantee.
BAU BAU!
I'm looking forward to having a bunch of fun with all of you guys.
It'll be wholesome.
But Ruffians!
It's the beginning of the week!
It's a Monday!
And Ruffians!
It's been a little while, but I think it's that time of the week!
And after, it's been a really really long time Moco-chan.
I think it's back!
Natto!
It's back!
And it's time to see just how much Moco-chan's been practicing and overcoming natto!
Right?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It's been a while, Moco-chan, so you should show us all the improvement you've made, right?
Do I have sesame oil?
No!
Advent Ruffians!
After watching Moco-chan do amazingly, even more amazing than last time, you'll be ready to challenge something new this week, right?
Right!
And that's why Moco-chan's gonna do her best to eat more natto this morning!
I don't have water!
There's a very special reason for this other than, you know, you could just hear improvement over a large period of time, right Moco-chan?
You know.
Wow, there was a Ruffian we spoke to doing a whole meat recently.
And he said that they really miss seeing Moco-chan do her best to conquer eating natto.
So that's why today, we're checking in on Moco-chan to see just how good she is at eating natto now.
Now every time you do a whole meat.
Ruffians gonna be like, OI!
I- I'm so sad!
FUWAMOCO CAN'T- MOCO-CHAN DOESN'T EVEN HAVE NO CHALLENGES ANYMORE!
Yeah.
And then they'll be like, oh well, I guess.
I love it when you put it like that.
Yeah, I love it the most.
Maybe this is your first time hearing about natto.
Natto is a very healthy, common breakfast food in Japan.
It's a super food.
It's very good for you.
Very rich in vitamins.
As for me, I love eating it happily everyday.
Moco-chan, you want to become like your older sister, right?
We're twins!
Henzutsu ni yokikamo.
You can't just say that!
You can't just say
Okay!
Moco-chan, what are you making those sounds for?
You were making them right!
Well!
Okay Moco-chan!
It was really stringy today.
First, let's say thank you to the farmers in Canada and the United States of America who worked hard to make this!
I'm still not Torchigi, Ruffians.
Yeah.
Why?
The last time I had Torchigi.
Not here.
Now we're closer to Torchigi.
I'm not here.
Yeah.
Okay!
Wow, Moco-chan!
Itadakimasu!
That's one bean, Moco-chan.
That's one bean.
What are you doing?
What are you doing, Moco-chan?
Where's that strong demon dog that we saw a few months ago?
Huh?
Only once we've cleared the challenge.
Why?
Why'd I get back into the group?
I don't know.
Stand with the eyes.
Definitely not stand.
I stand it!
I stand it, look!
Moco-chan, why are you making it sound like you're eating it when you're clearly not?
I'm trying to get it on my tongue.
Okay.
Huh?
Oh!
The tongue!
I can't tell if it's tight!
The tongue petted me!
It couldn't have to do a bit better than that.
It didn't go.
It didn't drop from the chopsticks.
3, 2.
Oh, 3, 2.
Moco-chan, that is nowhere close to eating.
It's not supposed to be like that.
It fell out, though.
It fell out of the mouth.
Moco-chan, you ready to eat more beans?
Can I just hide it under my tongue?
No, if it's gonna be this pathetic, we're gonna have to start from scratch again.
I'm gonna hide it under my tongue.
Oh my god!
Oh, oh, it's on the teeth?
I know it!
Moco-chan.
It was not a good idea to hide it under the tongue.
No.
Moco-chan.
There's no milk.
It's not gonna help with the taste.
I feel like they're squishier.
They're not squishier.
Why should she hide it?
That was her strategy.
I didn't tell her it would work.
Okay, Moco-chan.
You have 5 seconds.
I thought they said that there's no taste receptacles underneath the tongue.
2!
1!
Okay.
No!
What are you doing?
Okay, that is done.
Eat.
Chew.
Yum yum yum yum yum.
Yum yum yum yum.
Meow meow meow.
Moco-chan!
Sudden attack!
Sudden attack, Moco-chan!
Moco-chan!
Go for it!
No!
No, no, no!
Do I have a cough drop?
What is the big deal?
What is it, Moco-chan?
Wow, Ruffians.
I think we really have to go back to the beginning.
Oh, my tears.
Moco-chan!
I tried!
Tears of hard work.
I tried.
FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
I just want you to taste!
Moco-chan!
Moco-chan did her best to try to eat one piadato today.
And she put her all into it.
So you can do your best challenge something new.
I put your all into it.
Maybe it might take some tears too.
It's okay.
It happens.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
Next... Next we're gonna go take a look at the doggy.
Are you ready?
Look at today's Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's De-den!
FUWAMOCO!
I think it's been about a year now since we last saw De-den!
So cute!
Happy Christmas De-den!
Happy Christmas!
That's so happy!
What a good girl!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Moco-chan, how does that BAU BAU?
Wait, that's a bad noise!
Ren!
She's the Doggie of the Day today!
Good!
Yeah, I forgot!
Ren, she's so cute!
She's been by your side for so long!
Yeah!
I just love how soft she is!
Yeah, you could just dig your fingers right in there, huh?
Yeah!
Today I went on a walk.
We are out de-den!
I guess you know, well it's some sort of plant that has a tendency to make everything look very golden just like you!
It looks delicious.
I feel like if I walked through that field I'd end up looking golden too.
This looks like an amazing final summer walk, right?
It's the perfect way to end off the summer time.
Well, we hope that you not even let the summer walks come to an end here.
That you'll start to enjoy the fall walks too!
Different type of fall.
It's not good for pollen allergies.
Well, maybe we'll get to see you by then.
I'll see you when!
BAU BAU!
Next for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Over the last one year, you two have proven to be the strongest puppies I've ever known.
You've always tried to bring a smile to our faces despite all the difficulties, hardships, and sickness.
I really admire you.
Can you tell me how to become strong like you?
Well, I think Ruffians, you know, we try really, really, really hard to be as strong as possible in front of you, you know?
Because, you know, we want to protect your smile as much as we can.
And you know, we know that things are rough for you.
But you know, we also have hard times too!
And we try really hard to get through them without you noticing sometimes.
And sometimes we probably do better than other times.
But that's just because, Ruffians, we don't want you to worry at all!
We think the best way to get stronger is to just believe in yourself and your dreams.
And also maybe be a bit silly hot.
Stubborn.
Stubborn, silly, all that stuff.
All of that.
Does that answer the question?
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for all your submissions to FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Remember, if you have any works that you've been on recently, a Doggie of the Day, maybe a question to send us, or you happen to run into Pero, please, please send us it with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
That's the important part of FUWAMOCO Morning, so please let us include G.O.K.!
BAU BAU!
For our next stream, we have host G.G.A.!
We're really looking forward to it!
Let's go into the world of Holosatos.
You know, do our best at our brand new job being a Maddix.
And being all together with all our senpais.
So many senpais!
I feel like it's gonna be very busy.
It's gonna be a whole new experience for us Ruffians.
So please be there!
Let's have a lot of fun together, okay?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Are you excited, Ruffians?
It's gonna be a new experience for us!
Please be there, okay?
We're gonna do our best for now.
And on Saturday evening, we're doing the Voice of Mimicry show, the Koei Maneki Gou!
We're gonna make a bunch of sounds.
Because we're good at making sounds!
And that way we can win prizes, right?
We make a lot of unique sounds sometimes.
Sometimes it can be surprising.
And you know what?
We make the sound at the same time.
You can see how similar our sounds sounds like.
FUWAMOCO!
And then on Sunday evening, we're gonna be able to talk a bunch about doggy packs all of a sudden!
It's been one year since our doggy pack came to be!
And we're super excited to be able to talk about a bunch of things in the past year!
It's been a little while, so we're really looking forward to getting nice and comfy and cozy again!
I know it's gonna be a bit of a busy week, cause you know there's hololive today, we have the other streams too, and we have
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Gary Petit!
BAU BAU!
Ice Nightheart!
Broadhorse!
BAU BAU!
Curtis!
Mike L!
BAU BAU!
Oh yeah!
Vexo!
BAU BAU!
Choco and Chiyo!
Me too!
BAU BAU!
Umisora!
Jibanken!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!